procrastination is a trap that many of
us fall into it usually involves
ignoring an unpleasant but likely more
important task in favor of one that is
more enjoyable or easier if we
procrastinate over a long period of time
we can become demotivated and
disillusioned with our work which can
even lead to depression and job loss
here are some tips to avoid
procrastination one plan and organize
you are more likely to procrastinate if
you don't have an organized plan or idea
for completing your work investing in
planning and organizing your work is a
good idea start keeping track of all
your work and assignments when you're
organized it gives you a more orderly
and measured framework within which to
work sure prioritize work prioritizing
your work and assignments is another way
to help you avoid procrastination make a
to-do list of what needs to be completed
make sure you address the most critical
or time-sensitive assignments first then
work your way down the list get the hard
stuff out of the way first so that
everything that comes after it will seem
more manageable three set deadlines
another tip to avoid procrastination is
to set deadlines many people get stuck
and I'll do it tomorrow or eventually
cycle when in truth that day or
eventually never comes it's important to
set a specific date for when you want a
project or assignment to be completed
and to complete your projects and
assignments before the deadline that way
if something unexpected happens you
still have extra time to complete them
4. eliminate all distractions getting
rid of distractions is one of the most
efficient way to avoid procrastination
by limiting the number of distractions
around you you're more likely to get
done what you need to do
shut your phone off Retreat to a quiet
place and listen to classical music or
white noise to drown out any noise and
do your task being focused and dedicated
finally 5. reward yourself rewarding
yourself May create an incentive to
complete a task and help avoid
procrastination after working hard or
after completing tasks consider giving
yourself a reward it could be as simple
as once I finish this assignment I can
watch an episode of my favorite show
this will be a reward to our efforts
which will give us positive
reinforcement and motivates us to work
more efficiently thank you for watching
And subscribe for more